[Applause]
[Music]
look at that
that is the biggest crowd mtv has ever
ever had why
two words backstreet boys
in the 90s it was a great time to be in
the music business
things were booming and as a result
expensive parties big launches yeah that
was part of the culture
this is the era of nsync and the
backstreet boys this is the era where a
single hit
could sell you 10 million albums plus
they were just printing money
[Music]
you had the great sales of cds over that
period
dwarfing whatever had happened in the
industry before
the profits coming in will massive
it was a hell of a lot of fun from my
viewpoint
we were going to get better and better
all the time
[Music]
we really didn't foresee the change
in the technology
we'll be telling you tonight about a
method of compressing
audio data called mp3
[Music]
and um that was the end of everything we
know
[Music]
the birth of the mp3 was a seminal
moment for
all of media and entertainment it would
completely
change the music industry completely
disrupted it opened up people's minds
to what the future would be
[Music]
this music is free for downloading the
music industry is not
viable movies books television nothing
creative has any value anymore
the music industry simply did not
embrace the magnitude of the change
and it failed you can't fight progress
you can't fight
technology
[Music]
the mp3 totally changed people's
relationship
to the internet to culture and to how
society works
it's a fact that was so much bigger than
just the music industry
would you say that you love audio you
just
love it oh sure oh sure
i have to admit i got older so i'm not
as critical in listening as i've been
some decades ago but i
definitely love music and love audio
and i have to say with all this great
reproduction
technology the best is still to sit in a
concert hall
to hear real musicians
[Music]
when people call me the father of mp3 i
always have to add
no no i was as you sometimes say
standing
on the shoulders of giants
but my original contribution is really
some of the basic ideas to mp3
story of the mp3 really begins in west
germany
back then in the early 80s and even late
70s people
started trying to compress music
including my own thesis advisor
dieter said say cedra seitzer was a
visionary who came up with the mp3
he was seeing the original digitization
of music with a compact disc
and thinking instead of manufacturing
millions upon millions of plastic disks
why don't we store all the data in one
centralized computer
and then stream it to people in their
homes
so he applied for a patent to use the
phone system
to transmit music 1982
that's when they first had this idea but
at a huge
problem the compact disc took about a
million bits of information
to store one second of audio and the
pipe they were trying to send it through
the telephone could only do about 128
000 bits
for this to work they somehow had to
magically shrink the size of the compact
disk
by 90 percent or more the patent
examiner
looked at it and said no it's not
possible
essentially almost everyone thought this
was impossible there's no way to do this
but around 87 or 88 dieter seitzer's
brilliant graduate student brandenburg
made a breakthrough by taking advantage
of the sort of
obscure academic discipline
acoustics
the human ear has a lot of inherited
flaws
for example two tones that are close
together in pitch will begin to cancel
each other
out and therefore he realized much of
the information in the compact disc was
irrelevant
the ear couldn't actually hear it
so devised a series of mathematical
models to eliminate all of those
inefficient bits of data that you will
never hear
and in so doing he was in fact able to
shrink the music by an extraordinary
amount
with mp3 music nour which
is
what was done in the end exceeded the
expectations of everybody
[Music]
the functionality of what they put up
was relatively limited
you had to go and get a serial number
where you paid and license it to unlock
full functionality
but the way the software underground
worked in the 90s is that practically
these serial numbers were available
anywhere
we tried writing looks as a stone
software
we will send the public prosecutor after
you
which of course doesn't really work in
these days
it starts to percolate out of the
academic audio and computing sphere into
the broader public
and by 96 the pirates find out about him
[Music]
the years about 1997 1998
i'm in seventh grade a school
friend of mine said hey there's a way
you can listen to music
for free on your computer check this out
after i discovered my first mp3 it blew
the floodgates wide open that's all i
did
every single day every single night i
was the founder of the
mp3 piracy group known as audio pucks
we specialized in everything from punk
rock to ska
to hardcore and heavy metal
we had downloaders from indonesia japan
russia you name it people are
downloading
back then in the late 90s if you want to
find mp3s you would go into irc channels
it was a series of chat rooms that were
hidden and
invite only i eventually
found these great little channels that
kept membership
solid by enforcing a upload ratio
where you had to upload three songs or
two songs or whatever number
in order to download one song
so i would pull money together with my
friends in order to get
a cd rip a cd
and then compress that into an mp3
and then we would spend all night
uploading the album
putting it out on the internet we're
eventually able to keep repeating the
process
and have almost an assembly line
structure
and in our prime we had probably close
to a thousand
albums in our catalog
[Applause]
man that it was almost like a full-time
job just dedicated to
these song files
did you ever think like wow this is kind
of like i'm stealing from
these artists did that ever occur to you
you know in the late 90s we were idiots
we were kids yeah i i started this when
i was 12.
i didn't know what i was doing it wasn't
called piracy back then
it was just file sharing
in the late 90s my staff started
monitoring the
online space and we really did see a
significant amount of interest in mp3
all of a sudden because
of its ability to compress a music file
the latest advance called mp3 comes via
the internet
it's the future of music and audio i'm
sure that there are millions of you out
there who not
only understand what digital downloading
technology is about
but who use it daily to great personal
advantage
i think there really wasn't any sort of
panic in the industry
in the early days my team did look at it
and see
it as not really as much of a threat as
an opportunity
we used to call it the celestial jukebox
celestial jukebox it was a theoretical
construct at the time
every song ever made was going to be in
what we call the cloud
right now and would be instantaneously
available to anyone on the planet
simply by pressing a button on your
gizmo
but the industry really did not embrace
that opportunity
i think when we first heard the term mp3
we didn't really know if that was
important
or how it might be important and even if
it was important how did it affect us
[Music]
but there was an awareness that the
digital revolution was coming
and anybody who was in a senior position
had to say
how do we make this work for us
we began trying to find a way to
legitimately
sell music on the internet what systems
do we develop how do we deal with how we
sell it how do you price it
sony music said today it'll be the first
major recording company to sell new
releases
through the internet these virtual
singles be released at the same time as
cds go into the stores
we were working at it but the senior
executives
they still had the mentality of you
needed
a hard good and that was the basis of
their business
the music industry was making gobs of
money selling cds
that's the bottom line so companies like
mine mp3.com that went to them and said
hey
we want to work with you let's figure
out something that gives the consumer
some value and gives you some value
they didn't want to hear any of that
they tell me
no the computer is for word processing
and spreadsheets they couldn't see it
we had meeting after meeting after
meeting with companies with proposals
for new technological ideas um
generally who knew absolutely nothing
about how the record business worked
which made it difficult for them to
express how it was good for us
so uh basically all of this stuff was
for naught
and then pierre pierre came along and
changed everything
i just stopped going to school i left my
dorm room i didn't tell any of my
friends i just stopped going
[Music]
i knew that if i had told them what i
was planning on doing they would have
convinced me
not to do it or they would have they
would have questioned my decision to
leave
in 1999 observing that file sharing was
fun but was not easy
sean fanning and sean parker come around
and create
napster
[Music]
there were two teenagers hanging around
an irc chat channel and swapping mp3
files
now at the time there were all these mp3
files being created but there was no
sort of central
index where you could go download them
easily
and so fanning said why don't i create a
new technology that will
connect all these files together
something
called a peer-to-peer server my
computers appear and your computers
appear
the files that are on your computer i
have access to them and vice versa
so it was like the ultimate file trading
tool
and it facilitated really low friction
sharing of music
parker's role was essentially the face
of the organization
fanning wrote the code fanning kind of
did all the technical and computer side
stuff
i was spending two or three days in a
row sitting on a machine writing code
you know i pass out on the desk or on
the floor
it was just a blur
this is a guy who just sat in the
basement and cranked for six months
it was the first computer program he
ever wrote he went out and bought a
visual basic book
uh knew what he wanted to get to and
just kept at it
he was not to be deterred
and of course it took off
my head of anti-piracy frank creighton
came in my office and said i've just
found the most
fascinating thing it was napster
i put in you know madonna's holiday
and i was like whoa that's pretty
amazing that's like the celestial
jukebox we've been talking about this
for years
we immediately contacted them
and said you know really cool system but
you're infringing on copyright
well if you send us a list of all of
your songs we'll make sure that none of
them are on there
i said all right just start with the
billboard top 200 songs take those
off they said okay fine we'll try that
well
they didn't and it just grew and grew
and grew
it's called napster and is by far the
fastest way to download music from the
internet it allows anyone to copy
thousands of musical selections for free
and it spreads so quickly
that it's clogging computer networks on
hundreds of campuses
so this became hugely popular overnight
basically
it was really one of the first viral
apps
the hysteria over napster culminated in
i would say an riaa board meeting in
february of 2000.
it was in los angeles at the four
seasons hotel and i will never forget
this day
all of the heads of the labels literally
the titans
of the music business were in that room
i had somebody wheel in a pc and put
some speakers up
and i started doing a name that tune
give me your last five biggest hits
every single song that somebody named
was available on napster
[Music]
well give me some old ones like what you
know name older artists
that was on there
okay now tell me what you're releasing
next week
and sure enough you know 20 of the top
new
yet to be released songs were on there
as well
we used to have this line in the record
business that there was sort of nothing
a good hit couldn't fix
there was no screw-up a good hit
couldn't fix there was no amount of
money
lost on a deal that a good hit couldn't
fix
[Music]
i think that was the moment when people
said hmm
maybe a good hit can't fix this one
[Music]
you